c'est en musique qui a commencé cette
journée euros scola ou plus de 500
lycéens venus de 20 pays d'europe ont
découvert le parlement européen vendredi
dernier au programme comprendre les
enjeux de l'union européenne en se
glissant dans le rôle d'un député mais
auparavant chaque porte parole présenter
son école face à l'hémicycle
ce matin quand je suis arrivé dans le
problème en gt gt impressionné
honnêtement c'est super grand puis
franchement on est rentré dans l'entrée
je pensais qu'on était déjà rentré sauf
qu'en fait si on n'était pas du tout
rentrer encore et c'était un immense jeu
lever la tête voyez pas je voyais pas le
toit
21 élèves du lycée yvelinois issus de
filières cap1 bac professionnel ont fait
le voyage jusqu'en alsace un déplacement
dont chacun veut garder un souvenir mais
avec tout de même beaucoup d'enjeux ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que son
jeune et comme on a dit agir c'est la
jeunesse qui va le faire c'est la
jeunesse qu'est la relève et je pense
que c'est important que les jeunes
soient là présents ici et montrent leur
implication l'effet le plus important je
pense sera en langue il faudra qu'ils se
rendent compte que l'anglais est
important et combien important pour
pouvoir échanger avec les élèves les
différents pays une fois les
présentations terminées rien de tel
qu'un débat avec un député européen pour
s'adapter à cet univers institutionnels
suivi d'une initiation système de vote
électronique
après la pause déjeuner les lycéens se
sont répartis en six groupes de travail
autour de thèmes comme l'avenir de
l'europe où les migrations avant d'en
débattre dans l'hémicycle mais au milieu
de leurs collègues espagnols ou
lettonien la prise de parole dans une
langue étrangère s'avère parfois
difficile pour les élèves trappistes on
se rend compte que là la france à 15 ans
de retard entre
l'éducation en anglais entre les autres
pays de l'europe ça rien à voir
c'était vraiment formidable
il y avait tellement de sièges on était
sept cents personnes cette journée s'est
logiquement ponctuée par l'hymne à la
joie au cours duquel les jeunes lycéens
ont porté fièrement les drapeaux
européens